let's jump to this story from the Daily
Mail and talk about victories against
wokeness the inadvertent results of uh
what we're seeing now with Israel and
and Hamas billionaires who have pumped
$500 million into Ivy League schools
back out over failure to condemn the
Hamas Terror attacks on Israel Harvard
and upen face losing hundreds of
millions in future endowments up to 487
million could be lost amid Rising
tensions between Israel and Palestine
billionaires Ken Griffin has requested
Harvard take a robust stance in defense
of Isel so uh let's just put it this way
we've long talked about uh defunding
universities it's happening and it's
happening because these activist groups
came out in support of terrorists oh
there you go they had a line apparently
there was a line but they created they
created these people they created these
monsters these this is this is Dr
Frankenstein they created this and now
they're like oh I guess this isn't very
popular now time to undo the damage and
look like Heroes that's crazy Ken
Griffin pledged $300 million to Harvard
this year alone but contacted the head
of the University board to complain
about the teid response of President
Claudine gay so he's apparently not
hearing back and it looks like they're
going to start pulling pulling their
funding the the Claudine gay thing was
really fascinating because she put out
so you had all of these student groups
at Harvard what was it like 12 student
groups and they all submitted letters
basically in support of Hamas and like
against Israel and they all put out
these letters um and then you had these
companies these CEOs were like who is
who is in these student groups we don't
want to hire them and then you had like
Alum and trustees you know complaining
and saying you know we want to pull our
funding out you had Claud gay the
president of Harvard saying which I
think she's right to say is that she
supports Free Speech she supports the
free speech of the students at the
school right I'm always going to support
the Free Speech even though I totally
disagree with it she came out and said
that but this is at a un where people
get deplatformed for not using the right
pronouns or for saying that men aren't
women so it's a total hypocritical grift
is exactly what it is it's trash she
supports Free Speech when it's when it
protect convenient for her she she
supports Free Speech because she doesn't
have to say anything about these student
groups and she doesn't have to say
anything about the you know crazy
ideological warfare that's been waged
against the students of the United
States making them believe that
terrorism is good and America is bad
right um she doesn't have to do anything
legitimate she just has to like so I I I
support the defunding of these
universities I have long thought that
the problem with the student loan crisis
the the schools should pay it off with
their huge endowments yes yes absolutely
I agree with that and just it's sad for
me like just as a constitutional person
to think about how far how far Harvard
has fallen like John Adams went there
you know John Quincy Adams went there
like I mean now just but it hasn't been
that long time spring Army used to be in
Massachusetts and it isn't now John
Adams also he defended the British
soldiers during the Boston Massacre
which I have immense respect for yeah so
John ad even though he totally disagreed
with them yeah he he he believed so
powerfully that that they would get a
free trial if they were defended well
because that's that's what people were
like okay so he believed so powerfully
in this that he's like I will defend
them myself and his defense got there
were eight of them his defense got six
of them off and two of them instead of
death were marked with an m and that M
just meant manslaughter um yeah so that
and that was his doing that did that and
now it's like we are we are we are oh my
God I loved him but we were like I love
that you have a John Adams thing I have
a John Adams thing I do have you ever
seen Adams uh no watch it it's the best
series ever um so I saw 1776 on Bradway
if you think about how far away we are
yes so if you think about how far away
we are from from that from John Adams
representing the red coats and getting
six of them off and two of them from
death to a manslaughter brand on their
hand now look at like the J
Sixers yeah and the fact that the same
judge judge shutkin who has been
Prosecuting January 6th defendants uh
sometimes imposing sentences greater
than the Department of Justice even
asked for is now um the the judge
presiding over Trump's case I think is
absolutely insane she has so much bias
against him um she's she's being allowed
to do this she put a gag order on him
today because they don't like his social
media posts they yeah because they don't
want him to make fun of them right but
also they don't want him to be able to
speak in his own defense and they know
that the more he does speak in his own
defense and the more they prosecute him
the more popular he becomes in the
United States President G to talk about
Free Speech now well I have a conspiracy
about this I feel like they are doing
this totally illegally totally in front
of our faces totally unconstitutionally
and I it's going to go to scotus who's
going to be like this was really
unconstitutional what you did we are
overturning this you know he get him off
of house arrest cuz he's never going to
go to prison unless they build a new
Wing or whatever but he's going to go to
Mar laggo have a ankle bracelet or
whatever but they're going to say okay
this is unconstitutional and then
Congress is going to rise up or all the
Deep State and they're going to be like
this is why we need to pack the court
because this court is bias for Trump and
and and that's the only way to correct
this ill these are Trump judges that Lit
him off and it is undemocratic and
that's that's what's going to happen
which means we can't lose the house yes
yes
exactly and it's the only control that
there is and we don't have a speaker
this this this segment is supposed to be
a white pill and you know you guys are
you guys do you guys like Jordan what
who who do you like for speaker h i mean
Matt Gates you like gates for speaker I
don't think he's right of course Nom so
well no I don't think he wants to do it
and there's reasons why it's not
necessarily appropriate I mean he led
the charge against McCarthy but come on
how many people are
actually doing anything Jim Jordan's
great M but I mean you're still going to
get he's not perfect nobody is he's
better than he's a big talker he he
talks a big big talk big talk but he
doesn't always walk the walk so well he
has a lot of Investigations that he's
working on yeah appreciate it yeah I
think he could do a good job I think we
have to get someone I think this has
been fun in games but it's time to get a
speaker in place and if it's Jim Jordan
then about a speaker can be anybody like
who would you nominate for speaker Tim
Trump yeah okay who would you nominate
liby if I was nominating for someone for
speaker um I would have to look into it
a little more I don't I would not
nominate Trump for speaker because I
would like him to be president and I
don't think that what he can be so he's
going to fight five cases against him
four of which are criminal once he's
speaker those cases probably EV yeah
those cases go away uh I would nominate
Ron Paul I wouldn't I don't see him as
as I mean Ron Paul's interesting we'd
love to see him do stuff I do think that
he's old enough now where maybe wouldn't
be effective look I believe he will just
live forever and and and preside over
our country in our hearts and in our
minds but uh this is sort of the the
argument uh against people being too old
and being forced to work forever I think
that's not actually good for American
culture um like Diane Feinstein was
working literally until she Di and is
this like want yeah Ruth too I think
that's gross I really hope that when I'm
that a when I'm like substantially
younger than the age Diane Feinstein was
when she died I just get to like hang
out with grandbabies yeah this is what
this is what I pray for I think this is
what bothers me about American
politicians is you know f didn't get
into the Senate until she was 60 anyways
right so then she was in for essentially
four decades and died while serving I
don't think that that sets a good
precedent for the culture that they are
writing into the law right we need a
culture that supports a work life
balance and promotes people to spend
time with their families I don't like M
Romney but I do understand why he was
like I'm going to be in my mid 80s if I
run again maybe someone else should do
this job um and so with speaker of the
house I would love to see someone young
enough Ron Paul would be great a a
disciple of Ron Paul perhaps I just
can't name one off top of my head I
think it's one of those things I have
toi carefully research Dave Smith Dave
Smith can be speaker of the house he
that would be great he'd be roasting
these people banging the G and being
like you know it' be awesome yeah it
could be good I kind of like Jordan I
just think we have to do someone at this
point you know look look if we're if if
if we're going like pie in the sky make
your wishes come true
not Jo but I mean you want somebody who
knows how I mean the house Speaker the
house Speaker has to be an operator
whether we like it or not like that's
part of the job have you ever seen the
meme explaining like what the Joe ran
podcast is and it's like it's like a
breakdown of it's like it's like
basically a script written out and Joe's
like he mentioned something about
peanuts growing in trees and then
someone says peanuts don't grow in trees
actually grow underground and he goes
wait what what do you mean and he's like
Jamie pull that up and then he's like
whoa peanuts grow underr he's like yes
he's like wow and then he says something
like he's like the the meme is he goes
yeah they they couldn't grow on trees
because squirrels would F them up could
you imagine that squirrels would be
effing up peanut trees squirrels are
basically like little
chimps it would make cpan so interesting
if Joe Rogan was dud it be the most
nobody would turn it off there's a
reason why he's got the big podcast you
should be lobbying for Joe Rogan to be
speaker of the house if you want your
ratings to go get some get some new ad
deals for con Suddenly It's
legitimately depends on do we want do we
want an entertaining time or do we want
a productive time and maybe Joe Rogan
would be productive I'm telling you
there nothing just want I really want
the borders closed I want Trump would be
really entertaining too on top of it
allbody this is why Trump because Trump
no one's going to be able to go against
him Trump's going to come out and be
like we need to impeach Biden who wants
to run against Donald Trump you you're
going to go up for re-election in a year
and you're going to be the one guy who
said I told Trump no but the Senate
wouldn't take up any of the legislation
that they passed and it would never get
past the the president's desk there's
still subpoena power there's he's going
to be like you want to investigate we're
and yes and Jim Jordan is he going to do
it
maybe had a thing today Donald Trump
will say I want subpoenas on these
people and then the the moderate
Republicans they call him will have to
go back to the districts and say we told
Trump no knowing Trump's approval rating
and his and his polling levels they're
all going to be like I can't take that
risk unless they want to join the
Democratic party true which many of them
might well not many I'd say maybe a
handful would be like fine I guess I'm a
Democrat now I really don't think so
it's all going the other direction yeah
I think they don't even change their
party they just become because because
what they did they made they made it
like these are the the way that they
they break up magga Republican versus
every other Republican it's to be like
no you can be a republican you can be
Adam kinzinger and you can be Liz Cheney
but you cannot be Matt Gates like this
is the difference that's the line that's
too far yes they write they write you
know articles there I think the New York
Times you probably pull it up wrote an
article about the difference between
Republicans and magga Republicans just
like a tutorial so you knew what was
good Republican what was bad Republican
but this is a divide and conquer
technique this is well yeah because they
want to maintain the uni party that's
what it's really all about thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at Tim cast.com for
uncensored membersonly shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next
time